the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let me make a start on the left you
see the topic for today so we're doing
pretty well this completes my sort of
review of the highlights of linear
algebra so that's five lectures and it
I'll follow up on those five points
because the neat part is it really ties
together the whole subject I can values
energy a transpose a determinants pivots
they all come together each one gives a
test for positive definite matrices so
all that's where I'm going clear is
hoping to come in for a little bit of
the class to ask if anybody has started
on the on the homework and got Julia
rolling and got a yes from the auto
grader did anybody is anybody like no
you're taking a chance right Julia in
principle works but in practice it's
always an adventure the first time so we
chose this lab on convolution because it
was the first lab last time last year
and it doesn't ask for much mass at all
really just creating a matrix and
getting the auto grader to say yes
that's the right matrix so and we'll see
that matrix
we'll see this idea of convolution
in the right time at the right time
which is not that far off its signal
processing and it's early in part three
of the book okay so that if Claire comes
in she'll answer questions otherwise I
guess it would be emailing questions to
I realize that the deadline is not on
top of you so and you've got a whole
weekend to make Julia fly alright so
I'll start on the math then we had
symmetric matrix I can values of
matrices and specially symmetric
matrices and those have real eigenvalues
and I'll quickly show why and orthogonal
eigenvectors and I'll quickly show why
but I want to move to the new idea
positive definite matrices so these are
the best of the symmetric matrices there
are symmetric matrices that have
positive eigenvalues that's the easy way
to remember positive definite matrices
they have positive eigenvalues but it's
certainly not the easy way to test if I
give you a matrix like that well that's
only two by two we could actually find
the eigenvalues but we would like to
have other tests easier tests which
would be which would be equivalent to a
positive eigenvalues so these other
every one of those five tests any one of
those five tests is is all you need so
let me start with that example and ask
you to look and then I'm gonna discuss
those five separate points but can you
see well my question is is that matrix s
it's obviously symmetric is it positive
definite or not okay so you could
compute its eigenvalues since it's two
by two its energy I'll come back to that
because that's the most important one
number two is really fundamental number
three would ask you to factor that well
that's you don't
to take time with that well what do you
think is it positive definite or not I
see a expert in the front row saying no
and why is it no the answer is no that's
not a positive definite matrix where
does it let us down it's got all
positive numbers but that's not what
we're asking we're asking positive
eigenvalues positive determinants
positive pivots so how does it let us
down well which which is the easy test
to see that it fails determinant the
determinant is 15-16 so negative and
that's what so how's the determinate
connected to the eigenvalues everybody
yep it's the product so the two
eigenvalues of s they're real of course
and they multiply to give the
determinant which is minus one so one of
them is negative and one of them is
positive this matrix is an indefinite
matrix indefinite so how could I make it
positive definite okay just we can just
play with an example and then we see
these things happening let's see okay
well what shall I put in in place of the
five for example I could lower the four
or I can up the five or up the three I
can make the diagonal entries if I add
stuff to the main diagonal I'm making it
more positive so that's sort of
straightforward way so what number in
there would be safe six okay six would
be safe if I go up from five to six I've
got to do yeah so when I say here
leading determinants what does that mean
that so that's a that word leading means
something it means that I take the one
by one determinant it would have to pass
that just the determinant itself would
not do it let me give you an example
no.4 let me take minus 3 and minus 6
that would have the same determinant but
it's write the determinant would still
be 18 minus 16 - but it fails the tests
on the on the one by one and this passes
this passes the one by one test and the
two by two tests so that's what this
means here leading determinants are from
the upper left you have to check end
things because you've got n eigenvalues
and those are the end tests right and
have you noticed the connection to
pivots so let's just remember that small
item what would be the pivots because we
didn't take a long time on elimination
so what would be the pivots for for that
matrix 3 4 4 second well what's the
first pivot 3 sitting there the 1 1
entry would be the first pivot so the
pivots will be 3 and what's the second
pivot well maybe to see it clearly you
want me to take that elimination step
why don't I do it just so you'll see it
here so elimination would subtract some
multiple of Row one from Row two I I
would leave Row one alone I would
subtract some multiple to get a zero
there and what what's the multiple
what's the multiplier in that was 4/3
4/3 times Row one away from Row two
would produce that 0 but 4/3 times the 4
that would be 16 thirds and we're
subtracting it from 18 thirds I think
we've got two thirds left so the pivots
which is this in elimination or the 3
and the 2 thirds and of course they're
positive and actually you see the
immediate connection
this pivot is the 2 by 2 determinant
divided by the 1 by 1 determinant the 2
by 2 determinant we figured out 18-49 ax
16 was to the 1 by 1 determinant is 3
and sure enough that second pivot is 2/3
this is not so by example I'm
illustrating what these different tests
and again each test is all you need if
it passes one test it passes them all
and and we haven't found the eigenvalues
let me do the energy can I do energy
here okay so what's this I I'm saying
that this is the really the great test
that for me that's the definition of a
positive definite matrix and the word
energy comes in because it's quadratics
away kinetic energy or potential energy
so that's the energy in the vector X for
this matrix so let me compute it X
transpose X so let me put in s here the
original s and let me put in an any
vector X so say X Y or X 1 maybe
do you like X X Y is easier so that's
that's our vector X transpose this is
our matrix s and here's our vector X so
it's a function of x and y it's a pure
quadratic function can you do you know
what I get when I multiply that out I
get I get a very simple important type
of function shall we multiply it out
let's see so I multiply that by that
first so I get 3x plus 4y and 4x plus 6y
it's what I'm getting from the these two
and now I'm hitting that with the X Y
and now I'm gonna see the energy and
you'll see the pattern that's always
what math is about what's the pattern so
I have x times 3x 3x squared + iy x 6y
that's 6 y square and I have x times 4y
that's 4 XY z-- + iy times 4x that's for
more XY so I've got all those terms
every every term in every number in the
matrix gives me a piece of the energy
and you see that the diagonal numbers 3
& 6 those give me the diagonal pieces 3x
squared + 6 y squared and then the crust
but I maybe call them the cross terms
those give me 4 XY + 4 XY so really 8 X
Y so so you could call this thing 8 X Y
so that's my function that's my
quadratic that's my energy and I believe
that that is greater than 0 let me graph
the thing let me graph that energy
okay so here's a graph of my function f
of x and y here is X and here is y and
of course that's on the graph
zero zero at x equals zero y equals zero
the function is clearly zero everybody's
got his eye let me write that function
again here 3 x squared 6 y squared 8 X Y
actually you can see this is how I think
about that that function so 3x squared
is obviously carrying me upwards it's
not it never goes negative 6y squared
will never go negative 8 X Y can go
negative right if x and y have opposite
signs that that will go negative but the
question is do these do these positive
pieces overwhelm it and make the graph
go up like a bowl and the answer is yes
for a positive definite matrix so this
is a graph of a positive definite matrix
of a part of positive energy the energy
of a positive definite matrix so this is
the energy X transpose F X that I'm
graph and there it is
this is important this is important this
is the kind of function we like X
transpose X where s is positive definite
so the function goes up like that this
is what deep learning is about this
could be a loss function that you that
you minimize it could depend on a
hundred thousand variables or more and
it could come from the the error in the
difference between training data and
your
and the number you get the loss would be
some expression like that well I'll make
sense of those words as soon as I can
what I want to say is deep learning
neural Nets machine learning that the
big computation is to minimize an energy
is to minimize an energy now of course I
made the minimum easy to find because I
have pure squares
well that doesn't happen in practice of
course in practice we have linear terms
X transpose B or nonlinear yeah the loss
function doesn't have to be a thing
cross-entropy all kinds of things there
there's a whole dictionary of possible
loss functions but but this is the model
this is the model and I'll make it the
perfect model by just focusing on that
on that part well yeah by the way what
what what would create what would happen
if that was in there I shouldn't have
exited out so so well so quickly since I
just put it up there let me put it back
up
I saw it better rather okay
this is the kind of least squares
problem with some data be minimize that
so what would be the graph of this guy
can I just draw the same sort of picture
for that function will it be a bowl yes
if I have this term all that does is
move it off center here at x equals 0
well I still get 0 sorry I still go
through that point if this is the zero
vector I'm still getting 0 but this will
bring it below that would that would
produce a bowl like that actually it
would just be
same Bowl the bowl is would just be
shifted I could write that to show how
that happens so this is this is now
below zero this is the that's the
solution we're after
that tells us the weights in the neural
network I'm just using these words but
will soon have a meaning to them I want
to find that minimum in other words and
I want to find it for much more
complicated functions than that of
course if I minimize a quadratic that
means setting derivatives to zero I just
have linear equations probably I can I
could write everything down for that for
that thing so let's put in some
nonlinear stuff which which wiggles the
bowl makes it not so easy
can I look a month ahead how do you find
so this is a big part of mathematics
applied math optimization minimization
of a complicated function of a hundred
thousand variables that's the biggest
computation that's the reason machine
learning on big problems takes a week on
a GPU or multiple GPUs because you have
so many unknowns more than 100000 would
be quite normal in general let's just
have the pleasure of looking ahead for
one minute and then I'll come back to
real life here linear algebra yeah just
I can't resist thinking aloud how do you
find the minimum by the way these
functions both of them are convex so
that is convex
so I want to connect convex functions F
and what does convex mean it means well
that the graph is like that yeah I mean
not perfect it could it could but if if
it's a quadratic then convex means
positive definite or maybe in the
extreme positive semi-definite I'll have
to mention that yeah but but convex
means it goes up but it could have
Wiggles it doesn't have to be just
perfect squares and linear terms but
general things and for for deep learning
it will include none it'll go far beyond
quadratics but well it may not be convex
I guess that's also true yeah so so deep
learning has got serious problems
because those functions they may look
like this but then over here they could
go you know non convex they could dip
down a little more and you're looking
for this point or for this point still
I'm determined to tell you how to find
it so or a start on how you find it so
you're at some point there right sorry
start there somewhere on this surface
some X some some vector X is your start
x0 starting and we're going to just take
a step hopefully down down the bowl well
of course it would be fantastic to take
to get there in one step but that's not
going to happen that that would be
solving a big linear system very
expensive and a big nonlinear system so
really that's what we're trying to solve
a big nonlinear system and I should be
like on this picture
because here we can see where the
minimum is but they just shift so what
would you do if you had a starting point
and you wanted to go look for the
minimum but what's the natural idea
compute derivatives
you've got calculus on your side compute
the first derivatives so the first
derivatives with respect to X so so I
would compute the derivative of F with
respect to X and the derivative of F
with respect to Y and hundred thousand
more and that takes a little while and
now I've got the derivatives what do I
do I go that tells me the steepest
direction that tells me at that point
which way is fastest way down so I would
follow I would do a gradient descent I
would follow that gradient this is
called the gradient all the first
derivatives is called the gradient of F
the gradient gradient vector it's a
vector of course because F is a function
of lots of variables I would start down
in that direction and how far to go
that's like the million dollar question
in in deep learning as when it is it is
it gonna hit zero nope it's not it's not
and so you basically you go down until
it until they go in so you're traveling
here in the X along the gradient and
you're you're not even you're not gonna
hit zero you're right you're all going
here in some direction and you want to
go so you keep going down this thing
until it oh my I'm not Rembrandt here
I'm there your path down think of
yourself on a mountain
you're trying to go downhill so you take
as fast as you can so you take the
steepest route down until but but but
you have blinkers on you just once you
decided on a direction you go in that
direction of course yeah so so what will
happen you'll go down for a while and
then it will turn up again right when
you get sort of maybe close to the
bottom or maybe not you you're not going
to hit here and it's gonna miss that and
come up maybe I should draw it over here
whatever so this is it's called a line
surge to decide how far to go there and
then say okay stop and you can invest a
lot of time or a little time to decide
on that first stopping point and now
just tell me what do you do next
so now you're here what what now
recalculate the gradient find the
steepest way down from that point follow
it until it turns up or approximately
then you're at a new point so this is
gradient descent
that's a gradient descent the big
algorithm of deep learning of neural
Nets of machine learning great of
optimization you could say notice that
we didn't compute second derivatives if
if we computed second derivatives we
could have a fancier formula that could
account for the bending the curve here
but to compute second derivatives when
you've got hundreds of thousands of
variables is is not a lot of fun so most
effectively machine learning is limited
to first derivatives the gradient so
okay
so that's the general idea but there are
lots and lots of
decisions and why doesn't that how well
does that work
maybe maybe is a good way to good
question to ask does this work pretty
well you know or do we have to add more
ideas well it doesn't always work well
let me tell you what the trouble is I
don't so I'm Way off of like this is
this is like March or something but
anyway I'll finish the sentence so what
what's the problem with this gradient
descent idea it it turns out if you're
going down a narrow Valley I don't know
if you can sort of imagine a narrow
valley toward the bottom so so here's
here's the here's the bottom here's your
starting point and this is so I mean you
have to think of this as a bowl so the
yeah the bowl is the were the two
eigenvalues you could say are one and a
very small number the bowl is long and
thin are you with me
imagine a long thin bowl then what
happens for that case you you take
steepest descent but you cross the
valley and very soon you're climbing
again so you take very it's very small
steps just staggering back and forth
across this and getting slowly but too
slowly toward the bottom there so that's
why things have got to be improved you
can if you have I can value a very small
eigenvalue in a very large eigenvalue
those tell you the the shape of the bowl
of course and many cases will will be
like that have a small and a large I can
value and then you're spending all your
time
you're quickly going up the other side
down up down up down and you need a new
idea okay so that's really so this is
one major reason why positive-definite
is so important because
positive-definite gives pictures like
that but then we have this question of
are the eigenvalues sort of the same
size of course if the eigenvalues are
all equal what's my bowl like suppose we
suppose all the suppose I have the
identity so that's x squared plus y
squared is my function then it's a
perfectly circular Bowl what will happen
if I can you imagine a perfectly
circular like any any bowl in the
kitchen is probably most likely circular
and suppose I do gradient descent there
I start at some point on this perfectly
circular Bowl I start down and where do
I stop in that case do I hit bottom I do
by symmetry I'm gonna so so if I take x
squared plus y squared as my function
and I start somewhere I figure out the
gradient yeah the answer is I'll go
right through the center so really it's
positive positive eigen values positive
definite matrices give us a bowl but if
the eigenvalues are far apart that's
when we have problems ok I'm going back
to my job which is this list because you
really this is so nice
yeah right could you
well the homework that may be going out
this minute for middle of next week
gives you some exercises
with this let me do a couple of things a
couple of exercises here for example
suppose I have a positive different
matrix S and a positive definite matrix
T if I add those matrices is a result
positive definite so there's a perfect
math question and we hope to answer so
SMT positive definite what about s plus
T is that matrix positive definite okay
how do I answer such a question I look
at my five tests and I think can I use
it what which one will be good and the
whoa and one that won't tell me much is
the eigenvalues because the eigen values
of s plus T are not immediately clear
from the eigenvalues of s and T
separately I don't want to use that test
this is my favorite test so I'm going to
use that what about the energy in so
look at the energies so I look at X
transpose s plus T X and what's my
question in my mind here is that a
positive number or not for every X and
how am I going to answer that question
just separate those two into two pieces
right it's there in front of me it's
this one what's this one and both of
those are positive so the answer is yes
it is positive definite yes
you see how the energy just was right I
don't want to compute the pivots or any
determinants that would be like a
nightmare trying to find determinants
for s plus T but this one just doesn't
immediately what else would be a good
example to start with what about their
sin verse is that positive definite yes
positive definite and I want to ask
about its inverse so int inverse is a
symmetric matrix and is it positive
definite and the answer yes yes I got
five tests 20% chance of picking the
right one determinants not good the
first one is great
the first one is the good one for this
question because the eigen values so the
answer is yes yes yes this is has eigen
values so what are the eigenvalues of s
inverse 1 over lambda so yes okay right
yep
what about yeah let me ask just one more
question of this same sort suppose I
have a matrix s and suppose I multiply
it by another matrix oh well okay
suppose yeah yep suppose I have suppose
I asked you about s times another matrix
M
would that be positive definite or not
now I'm gonna tell you the answer the
answer is that the question wasn't any
good because that matrix is probably not
symmetric and I'm only dealing with
symmetric matrices matrices have to be
symmetric before I can before I know
they have real eigenvalues and I can ask
these questions so that's not good but I
could oh let's see well let me hear ya
let me let me put it in an orthogonal
guy well they're still that's not
symmetric but if I put C its transpose
over there then I made it symmetric oh
dear I may be getting myself in trouble
here so I'm starting with a positive
definite s I'm hitting with an
orthogonal matrix and it's transpose and
I sort of my instinct carried me here
because I know that that's still
symmetric right everybody sees that if I
transpose this Q transpose will come
here yes Q will go there it'll be some
checks symmetric now is that positive
definite oh yes we can't answer that can
we
is that positive definite so remember
that this is an orthogonal matrix so I'm
also if you wanted me to write it that
way I could
and what about positive definiteness of
that thing the answer I think is yes do
you agree it is positive definite give
me a reason though why is this positive
definite big so that word similar so
what this is a similar matrix to S do
you remember what similar means from
last time it means that some m and its
inverse or here we
they are and so what's the what's the
consequence of being similar what do I
know about a matrix that's similar to s
it has the same eigenvalues and
therefore we're good right or I could go
this way I could energy I like energy so
let me try that one X transpose Q
transpose su X that would be the energy
and what am I trying to show I'm trying
to show it's positive so of course my as
soon as I see that like just waiting for
me to the QX be something called Y maybe
and then what will this be my Y
transpose so this this energy would be
the same as Y transpose s Y and what do
I know about that it's positive because
that's an energy in the Y for the Y
vector so one way or another we get the
answer yes to that question ok ok let me
introduce the idea of semi-definite
semi-definite is the borderline so so
what did we have we had three four four
and then when it was five you told me
indefinite and negative eigenvalue when
it was six you told me two positive
eigenvalues definite what's the
borderline
what's the borderline there it's not
it's not going to be an integer but it's
well what do I mean what am I looking
for it the borderline well yeah so tell
me again sixteen over three that sounds
right why is that the borderline because
now the determinant is zero its singular
it has a zero eigenvalue there's a zero
eigenvalue so that's what semi definite
means lambdas are greater equal to zero
wait a minute that has a zero eigenvalue
because it's determinant is zero how do
i know that the other eigenvalue is
positive could could the could it be
that the other right so this is the semi
definite case we hope but we better
finish that reasoning how do I know that
the other eigenvalue is positive the
trace because the adding 3 plus 16 over
3 whatever the heck that might give it
certainly gives a positive number and
that will be lambda 1 plus lambda 2
that's the trace but lambda 2 is 0 we
know from this it's singular so we know
where lambda 2 is 0 so lambda 1 must be
3 plus 5 5 in a service lambda the
lambdas must be 8 Messrs 3 plus 5 and
1/3 and so that's a positive
semi-definite oh if you think of the
positive definite matrices as some clump
in matrix space then the positive
semi-definite ones are sort of the edge
of that clump they're the boundary of
the clump the ones that are not quite
inside but not outside either there
they're lying right on the edge of
positive definite matrices let me just
take a so what about what about a matrix
of all ones what's the what's the story
on that one positive definite all the
numbers are positive or positive semi
definite or indefinite what do you think
here one more all one's semi definite
sounds like a good guess
you know what the eigenvalues of this
matrix would be 3 0 & 0 why did you say
that because we only have the rank is
yeah introduce that key where the rank
is 1 so there's only one nonzero eigen
value and then the trace tells me it's
that that number is 3 so this is a
positive positive semi definite matrix
so so all these all these tests change a
little for semi definite the eigenvalue
is greater or equal the energies greater
or equal to 0 the a transpose a but now
I don't require oh I didn't discuss this
but but semi definite would allow
dependent columns by the way
you got to do this for me right that
matrix as a transpose times a just to
see that it's semi definite because so
write that as a transpose a yeah if it's
a rank one matrix you know how to what
it must look like a transfer was a how
many terms am I going to have in in this
and now I'm thinking back to the very
beginning of this course if I pulled off
the pieces in general this is lambda one
times the first eigenvector times the
first eigenvector transpose yeah would
just be a vector of three ones yeah so
so this would be the usual picture that
this is the same as the Q lambda Q
transpose this is this is the big big
fact for any symmetric matrix and this
is symmetric but its rank is only one so
that so that lambda two is zero for that
matrix lambda 3 is zero for that matrix
and and the one eigen vector is the
vector 1 1 1 and the eigen so this would
be 3 times 1 1 1 oh I have to do yeah so
I was going to do 3 times 1 1 1 times 1
1 1 but that gives me 3 3 3 that's not
right I have to normalize them that's
right
yeah so that's a vector of whose length
is square root of 3 so I have to divide
by that divide by it and then the 3
cancels the square root of threes and
I'm just left with the 1 1 1 1 1 1
so there is a matrix one of our building
block type matrices because it only has
one nonzero eigen value it's rank is 1
so it could not be positive definite
it's it's singular but it is positive
semi definite because that eigen value
is positive okay
so you got the idea of positive definite
matrices again all five of those any one
of those five tests is enough to show
that it's positive definite and so
what's my goal next week is the singular
value decomposition and all that that
leads us to that's that's where we're
there now ready for at the SVD okay have
a good weekend and see ya oh I see you
on Tuesday I guess right not Monday but
Tuesday next week